.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
>> LET ME BE CLEAR, THE
EVACUATION OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE FROM KABUL WILL BE HARD
AND PAINFUL NO MATTER WHEN IT
STARTED, WHEN WE BEGAN.
THERE IS NO WAY TO EVACUATE THIS
MANY PEOPLE WITHOUT PAIN AND
LOSS AND HEARTBREAKING IMAGES
THAT YOU SEE IN TELEVISION, BUT
WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO AND A
LOT CAN STILL GO WRONG.
>> Dana: A LOT CAN STILL GO
WRONG, TALK ABOUT THE CHAOS IN
AFGHANISTAN, SAYING THAT THEY
COULD EXTEND THE DEADLINE TO GET
EVERYONE OUT SAFELY, BUT THE
TALIBAN IS DRAWING A LINE SAYING
THERE WILL BE CONSEQUENCES IF HE
GOES BEYOND THAT DATE.
AND LEARNING OF AN INTERNAL
INTELLIGENCE REPORT WARNING THE
U.S. THAT ISIS AND AL QAEDA ARE
GOING TO PRESSURE AMERICAN
FORCES TO LEAVE BEFORE THE
DEADLINE BY LAUNCHING AN ATTACK
ON THE AIRPORT.
THE WHITE HOUSE ASKED ABOUT THE
THREAT AL QAEDA POSED.
>> SO FRIDAY THE PRESIDENT SAID
THAT WE GOT RID OF AL QAEDA IN
AFGHANISTAN.
A SUNDAY THE SECRETARY OF STATE
SAID THERE IS AL QAEDA IN
AFGHANISTAN.
SO ARE YOU PRESENTING THE
PRESIDENT WITH THE FULL PICTURE?
OR IS HE JUST MISAPPLYING THE
INTELLIGENCE WHEN HE MAKES THESE
PUBLIC STATEMENTS?
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS REFERRING
TO AL QAEDA'S CAPABILITY TO
ATTACK THE UNITED STATES.
WHICH THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
TELLS US TODAY IS NOT PRESENT IN
AFGHANISTAN.
WHAT IS PRESENT IN AFGHANISTAN
RIGHT NOW TO OUR FORCES AT THE
AIRPORT IS A SERIOUS THREAT FROM
ISIS THAT WE WILL TRY TO DEAL
WITH AND OF COURSE THERE IS THE
POSSIBILITY THAT AL QAEDA COULD
RECONSTITUTE AN EXTERNAL
CAPABILITY ON AFGHANISTAN.
>> Dana: THIS IS BETWEEN
PETER DOOCY ASKING AMERICANS AND
BEING STRANDED IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> MOST OF THE CRITICISM IS NOT
OF LEAVING AFGHANISTAN, IT IS
THE WAY THAT HE HAS ORDERED IT
TO HAPPEN BY PULLING THE TROOPS
BEFORE GETTING THESE AMERICANS
WHO ARE STRANDED.
DOES HE HAVE A SENSE OF THAT?
>> I THINK IT'S CORRESPONDED --
IRRESPONSIBLE TO SAY AMERICANS
ARE STRANDED.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO BRINGING
AMERICANS WHO WANT TO COME HOME
HOME.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAPPEN OVER THE WEEKEND WAS
PRESIDENT BIDEN WOULD SAY
SOMETHING AND HE WOULD LOOK AT
THE SCREEN AND SAY THAT'S NOT
EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE HEARING.
AND WE TALKED TO AMERICAN
CITIZENS, AND HIS WIFE WAS
THERE, AND WE TALKED TO HIM AND
WERE DISTRESSED, SO THEY CAN'T
GET THROUGH TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> Jesse: STRANDED MEANS IF
YOU WANT TO LEAVE SOMEWHERE AND
YOU CAN'T, THAT'S THE DEFINITION
OF STRANDED, DO YOU THINK
AMERICANS CAN JUST GO TO THE
KABUL AIRPORT AND TAKE UP ON THE
NEXT FLIGHT?
THEY CAN'T, THEY ARE STRANDED
PET I DON'T KNOW WHY SHE IS
ARGUING ABOUT THE WORD, IT
REMINDS ME OF IT'S NOT A CRISIS
AT THE BORDER, IT'S A CHALLENGE.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT
MESSAGING, AT FIRST IT WAS
THINGS ARE GOING GREAT, AND NOW
IT'S, IT WAS ALWAYS GOING TO BE
A MESS.
OR, WE PLAN FOR THIS, AND THEN,
OH, NO ONE COULD A PLAN FOR
THIS.
OR PEOPLE ARE CLINGING FROM THE
WINGS OF AIRPLANES, OH, THAT WAS
FOUR DAYS AGO, NOW IT'S MY HEART
BREAKS FOR THESE PEOPLE.
HEY, GET TO THE AIRPORT AND YOU
WILL GET OUT AS SOON AS YOU CAN.
ACTUALLY, NO, DON'T GO TO THE
AIRPORT NOW, ELEVATED TERROR
THREATS, OR WE WILL GET OUT BY
SEPTEMBER 11TH, NO, WE WILL HAVE
TO POSSIBLY STAY PASSED
SEPTEMBER 11TH, AND NOW IT IS A
GAME OF CHICKEN WITH THE TALIBAN
THAT HAVE A DEAL AFTER SEPTEMBEO
YOU GET INTO AN ACTUAL HOSTAGE
CRISIS WITH LIVE ROUNDS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
CAPABLE OF.
FIRING BULLETS INTO A CROWD.
IN GETTING THERE TEETH KNOCKED
OUT.
AND AMERICANS BEING BEATEN.
AND WE HAD TO GO TO THE TALIBAN,
HERE IS MY PASSPORT, THEY RIP IT
UP OR THEY ASK FOR THE BRIDE.
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY, OKAY,
MAYBE YOU COME UP WITH SOME
MONEY TOMORROW.
THAT'S HOW IT IS.
YOU CAN'T HAVE A PLAN LIKE THIS
WHERE YOU ARE AT THE MERCY OF A
TERRORIST ORGANIZATION, BIDEN
STRANDED AMERICANS IN A WAR ZONE
AND TRY TO GO BACK ON VACATION,
DANA, CAN YOU IMAGINE ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT TRYING TO PULL THAT
OFF?
CREATING THE CRISIS AND THE
ENEMY ON VACATION.
AND PASSION AND CONFIDENT, HAS
NOT SHOWN EITHER.
>> Dana: WHAT ABOUT THE DIP ON
APPROVAL AND LOTS OF DIFFERENT
AREAS THAT THERE IS BIPARTISAN
DISAPPROVAL OF HOW THIS WAS
HANDLED?
>> Jessica: I THINK IT SERIOUS
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION COMING TO
SEE THE BRIEFINGS INCREASED
TENFOLD FROM WHERE WE WERE LAST
WEEK, WHEN EVERY GOING TO HEAR
FROM SOMEONE AND I WE HAVE
MULTIPLE WITH SULLIVAN AT THE
PRESIDENT SPEAKING OVER THE
WEEKEND AND HAD A HURRICANE TO
DEAL WITH, SO THEY OBVIOUSLY
KNOW IT'S INCREDIBLY SERIOUS,
THE POLLING IT SEEMS LIKE TOOK
THE BIGGEST DEBT BECAUSE OF THE
COVERT RESPONSE, WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL TALK
ABOUT LATER IN THE SHOW AS WELL,
A HUGE CRISIS ON HIS PLATE, BUT
THE DICHOTOMY BETWEEN WHAT YOU
ARE HEARING AND THE IMAGES IS
SOMETHING THAT IS REALLY HARD TO
TAKE ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU SEE A
2-YEAR-OLD TRAMPLED.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT YOU CAN'T
UNSEE IN YOUR LIFE AND I THINK
THAT WHAT WE HAVE BEEN NOTICING,
AT LEAST WHAT I'VE BEEN NOTICING
IS THAT SHIFT TO FOCUSING ON HOW
ARE WE GOING TO GET THESE PEOPLE
OUT AND THAT AUGUST 31ST
DEADLINE?
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT NEGOTIATING
WITH A NORMAL GOVERNMENT, WE ARE
NEGOTIATING WITH TERRORISTS WHO
RUN THE COUNTRY.
AN AUGUST 31ST IF THEY EVEN HOLD
TO THAT IS ONLY EIGHT DAYS AWAY.
SO IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE
WHAT COMES OUT OF THE G7 MEETING
TOMORROW, CONVENING IF THEY HAVE
A PLAN, BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE
THEY ARE ACTUALLY MAKING A GOOD
AMOUNT OF PROGRESS.
>> Dana: IT FEELS LIKE THEY
ARE NOT LEADING FROM BEHIND IN
THIS SITUATION, THIS IS ABOUT
ISIS IN THE CONTROL ROOM AS YOU
PULL THIS ONE UP, TYRUS,
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS HE
UNDERSTANDS THE THREAT OF ISIS,
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> WE ARE MAINTAINING THE COST
OF THIS TO MONITOR AND DISRUPT
THREATS FROM ANY SOURCE
INCLUDING THE LIKELY SOURCE
BEING ISIS.
BUT WE ARE UNDER NO ILLUSIONS
ABOUT THE THREAT EVEN THOUGH WE
ARE MOVING BACK THE PERIMETER.
SIGNIFICANTLY.
WE ARE WORKING HARD AS FAST AS
HE CAN TO GET PEOPLE OUT.
THAT'S THE MISSION.
>> Dana: THE PERIMETER HAS
BEEN DISPUTED BACK AND FORTH,
MANY AMERICANS COULD BE
SURPRISED TO HEAR THE THREAT OF
ISIS?
>> THE OPTICS, WE ARE SEEING THE
OPTICS.
AND JESSE, YOU'RE SO RIGHT,
TRYING TO PAINT THE PICTURE THAT
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING BY THE
BOOK AND BAD THINGS WILL HAPPEN.
THE SIMPLEST THING WAS BEFORE
YOU PULL THE TROOPS OUT, YOU GET
THE OTHER PEOPLE OUT.
NEITHER ONE OF US ARE MILITARY
GUYS AND IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE
TO US, NOW WE ARE SEEING THE
OBJECTS OF YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
SAY THAT IT IS THE TALIBAN THAT
IS DOING THIS, BUT NOW WE WILL
HEAR THAT WE DID NOT KNOW THAT
ISIS IS GOING TO COME BACK,
BECAUSE THE TALIBAN IN ITSELF
WHEN THEY TALK TO THE
GOVERNMENT, THIS IS NOT A
UNIFIED GROUP, THEY ARE
BASICALLY TRIBES OF DIFFERENT
LITTLE WARLORDS THAT DO
DIFFERENT THINGS.
THEY HAVE NO CONTROL OVER WHAT
THEIR SOLDIERS DO OVER THE FIELD
TO CIVILIANS, AND WHEN THEY ARE
TAUGHT TO GO TO THE AIRPORT IT'S
WHAT MOB CAN GET THROUGH
FASTEST?
THEY ARE NOT EVEN GETTING A
CHANCE TO VENT PEOPLE AND THINGS
LIKE THAT BECAUSE THEY ARE
CLIMBING OVER THE WALLS, WHY?
BECAUSE THEY ARE GETTING SHOT IN
THE STREETS.
THE WOMEN ARE GETTING BEAT UP.
THERE IS NOTHING ABOUT WHAT HE
IS TALKING ABOUT MATCHES WHAT WE
ARE SEEING ON THE GROUND.
AND IT WILL BE THE BOOTS, NOT
THE SUITS THAT SAVE THE DAY.
>> Dana: YOU CAN TALK ABOUT
WHATEVER YOU WANT, BUT THIS IS
ABOUT ISIS AND AL QAEDA, WATCH
THE EXCHANGE BETWEEN
CHRIS WALLACE ON
"FOX NEWS SUNDAY" AND THE
SECRETARY OF STATE.
>> IS AL QAEDA GONE FROM
AFGHANISTAN?
>> THEIR CAPACITY TO DO WHAT IT
DID ON 9/11 TO ATTACK US AND OUR
PARTNERS AND ALLIES FROM
AFGHANISTAN IS VASTLY, VASTLY
DIMINISHED.
>> IS IT GONE?
>> ARE THERE AL QAEDA MEMBERS
AND REMNANTS IN AFGHANISTAN?
YES.
>> Dana: THERE WAS THE
HANDLING OF THE EVACUATION, BUT
THEN WHAT DO WE DO NOW TO KEEP
EVERYONE SAFE?
>> Kennedy: IT'S THAT THEN
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO NOW THAT
WILL ONLY GET WORSE AND WORSE
AND WORSE AND MAKES IT MORE
DANGEROUS FOR THE AMERICANS THAT
ARE STRANDED THEY ARE.
THEY ARE STRANDED, THAT REQUIRES
A SENSE OF URGENCY.
AND HEARING ONE THING FROM THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, AND
PEOPLE AT THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT.
AND HEARING SOMETHING COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT IN A DEFENSIVE PASTOR
FROM THE PRESIDENT.
NOTHING FROM THE VICE PRESIDENT
ON THIS, BUT IF I HAD A FAMILY
MEMBER OR, OR SOMEONE TO
TRANSLATE FOR ME OR HELP ME OUT
WHILE I WAS DOING A TOUR IN
AFGHANISTAN, AND LESS THEY ARE,
THE PRESS SECRETARY SAYING, HOW
DARE YOU?
USE THE WORD STRANDED.
IT'S HER LAWS BOSS WHO IS
SENDING PEOPLE TO DIE.
AND IT'S THE BOOTS WHO ARE BEING
SENT INTO A SITUATION THAT IS
GOING WORSE AND WORSE BY THE
DAY, BY THE SUIT, AND THEY DON'T
HAVE AN ANSWER FOR IT, AND I
DON'T TRUST THEIR INTELLIGENCE
WHEN THEY SAY, OH COMING OUT,
AL QAEDA IS GONE, HOW DO YOU
KNOW THAT?
I DON'T TRUST Y